so you're a part of the 1% in America
you've got a business that's making you
money and you've got American employees
doing the work for you but ironically
even though you're the one giving them a
job and you're paying them the highest
salaries in the world these employees
that you enrich are completely
ungrateful you give them ridiculous
things like vacation days sick days paid
leave you got to pay for payroll taxes
Healthcare benefits and yet they don't
even work hard they do the bare minimum
they lie and pretend to be sick most of
them are just going to quit after a year
for another job to advance their career
and if they do stick around even though
they're doing the bare minimum they're
guaranteed to store him into your office
at the end of the year and demand a
raise even though they know full well
they don't deserve it and guess what if
you don't fire them in the right way or
you call them by the wrong pronoun they
are going to sue you been served you've
been served you've been served American
employees are simply not worth the
trouble you got to find a way to replace
these ungrateful sobs with a cheaper
alternative if we're going to turn this
company around we got to start cutting
the crust off this sandwich after all
they're just going to blow the salary
you pay them anyways why not just skip
all the trouble and just not pay them in
the first place you're fired get out of
here go on pack your up and get out of
here now you may be wondering but Jake
how am I supposed to do that I need
these ungratefuls what am I supposed to
do replace them with cheap labor from
India or the Philippines we're talking
high level roles like creatives account
Executives client success managers
bookkeepers there's no way an Indian or
a Filipino can do this work they can't
even speak English calm down calm down
everyone
take a deep breath because what if I
told you you could what if I told you
you could replace pretty much every
single American employee with dirt cheap
labor from poor countries what if I told
you these workers would not only be dirt
cheap but they would actually be
grateful for you that they would
actually show you some respect and what
if I told you that these workers could
do just as good of a job as your
American employees if not better while
speaking great English with some even
speaking perfect English with no accents
see everyone has accepted that
Outsourcing hard labor to China is much
better you can easily train some race
Patty villagers to assemble one piece of
an iPhone with just a few minutes of
training but knowledge jobs that seems
like a far stretch but think about it
most poor countries have internet most
poor countries teach English in school
because they know that if they want to
make money they better know a little
English and all these poor countries
have the same access to the same free
tutorials on every skill of imaginable
just like you and I have except who's
more motivated some Filipino dude in his
late 20s or early 30s that's about to
get married and needs to feed his entire
extended family so he's devouring every
single little thing he can find out how
to get good at social media management
or Amanda over there from East Village
that like just wants to inspire people
on Tik Tok even though she's never
needed to work for a single thing in her
life yeah I'll take the Filipino for 80
to 90% less money every single day of
the week the biggest corporations in the
world all exploit cheap labor for a
reason because it works but if it makes
you feel better we can call it a much
more polite sounding term a term like
globalization stay dangerous and this is
how to exploit cheap labor
legally
okay aspiring Exploder the first step in
your journey is to set aside your
prejudices about people from poor
countries and you got to accept that
practically any American can be replaced
in just the Philippines alone Google
employs it service providers software
developer analytical consultants and a
whole lot more while United Health Group
outsources is Consulting customer
service engineering and project
management even Wells Fargo as
outsourced workers in highly skilled
knowledge jobs like fraud investigation
financial accounting and payroll
Consulting and these are just three
examples plenty of Fortune 500 companies
are doing this exact same thing all over
the world so think about it this way if
Wells Fargo is able to train a Filipino
on something as important as fraud
investigation if Google the most
powerful software company in the world
is able to Outsource their software
development to a Filipino then maybe
these people from these poor countries
are much more capable than you may have
thought maybe you can replace Timmy with
someone just as good and cheaper that is
Step number one and now that we have
that out of the way step number two is
to understand just how good and most
motivated these poor workers can
[Music]
be put yourself in the shoes of someone
in India or the Philippines you grew up
dirt poor you've always have to work
hard in your culture is normal to get
married early and have kids it's also
normal to live with your extended family
and support them I mean it's not like
your parents have a 41 care or something
you learn English in school or
university you got some degree at your
local University but the local jobs in
your country absolutely suck they'll
work you to the Bone you'll barely make
enough money to support yourself much or
less your entire family and there's no
room for advancement and that's if you
can find a job in many of these
countries even if you have a degree many
people still find themselves working a
hard labor job because there are just no
good jobs available take an accountant
in India for example for the most part
accounting is very standardized it's
hard to screw up if you're trained
unless you're actively trying to commit
fraud this means that someone who
graduated as an accountant in India
probably has close to the exact same
skills and knowledge as someone who
graduated as an accountant in America
but if you were to employ an accountant
in India full-time it would only cost
around
$7,200 a year at $7,200 a year they're
only making around $360 an hour still
really good money for them compared to
the jobs they can get but they give
about this what if you did something
super crazy and paid them $5 an hour
heck maybe even $7 an hour almost double
the average salary you generous
capitalist do you think he's going to be
insanely grateful do you think he's
going to work extra hard to make sure
he's doing everything to your standards
and that you're happy with him yes all
that for not even minimum wage in
America now compare that to an American
that you pay $30 an hour for something
the person in America isn't going to do
a good job for $30 an hour they've got
student debt mortgages car payments a
dream to chase remember all they're
going to think is oh $30 an hour that
cheap bastard and they'll just half ass
the job until they found a better one so
now that you understand where these
people are coming from now it's time to
move on to step number three
understanding the
[Music]
math let's say you have a business that
sells something for $100 maybe you're an
agency and you're selling a website
design or an email marketing campaign
for example and let's say it takes your
American employee 3 hours to fulfill the
service you pay this employee $25 an
hour so overall it cost you $75 in
expenses to keep it simple let's assume
there's no other expenses that leaves
you with a profit of $25 or a 25% profit
margin only getting to keep $25 for
every $100 you bring in isn't great but
hey most businesses with American
employees are like that so you're not
alone but let's say you replace that
expensive American employee with someone
from a cheap country like India where
the going rate for this position is just
$5 an hour now I can already hear you
say but Jake I may be only paying them
$5 an hour but what if they're not as
good as my American employee what if
they're slower less efficient okay fair
enough let's assume that your new Indian
worker is less efficient than your
American employee so instead of it
taking them 3 hours to fulfill the
service it takes them a little longer to
get acquainted maybe they just need to
move a little slower or maybe they're
literally just logging more hours than
they're actually working so it takes
them more like 6 hours to complete the
task most business owners would just
stop right there and say this person
sucks they're ripping me off fired but
hold on a minute because even if they're
only half as efficient as your American
worker let's do the math 6 hours at $5
an hour equals just $30 that's 60% less
money than what it cost your American
employee meaning instead of making a
measly $25 you were now profiting and
whopping $70 that's right just by
Outsourcing to a cheaper country even
though now you're technically twice as
inefficient you still went from a bad
profit margin of just 25% to unstained
70% profit margin so who cares if it
takes this guy 6 hours instead of three
just hire another one to help him out
now you have two workers filling two
orders bringing in $200 in revenue for
just $60 in expenses $60 which is is
still lower than paying your one
American employee but now you're
fulfilling more orders taking in more
customers and growing your company much
much faster and this is just a
theoretical example let's go back to the
accountant for example again an
accountant train in India versus the us
is going to have mostly the same skill
the only difference is employing the
accountant in India full-time cost
around just $7,200 a year while
employing an American accountant is
going to set you back at least $60,000 a
year not including all the other cost
that we mentioned earlier meaning that
by going with the inding accountant you
get to reduce your payroll by
88% for the exact same service okay so
you're sold you know they have the skill
you know they have the motivation and
the math makes sense so now it's time to
fire all these lazy Americans but wait
where do you even find these people in
the first
[Music]
place there are plenty of websites where
you can find cheap remote workers but up
upwork is probably the best place to
start not affiliated on upwork you can
find remote workers for every possible
position from every corner of the world
it's as simple as posting a job post
making sure you're as detailed and
enticing as possible with your job post
title and description you can choose
which countries you want to Target and
then boom the applications will start
rolling in then it's a matter of
reviewing the applicants shortlisting
them interviewing the ones you like
testing them out and hopefully hiring
one you like the only problem you're
going to run into is that you're going
to have to shift through a lot of bad
applicants that's because although
everything we talked about earlier about
these people being motivated and skilled
is true there's still going to be a ton
of bad applicants on these websites
that's because platforms like upwork
have a very low barrier for entry think
about it anyone can pirate Photoshop
watch a few YouTube tutorials and then
call themselves a graphic designer
anyone can lie about their experience to
say they're great as sales Finance or
operations they can plagiarize their
portfolio and you'll only find out once
it's too late and you've already wasted
all this time reviewing applicants
hiring them training them Etc and then
you'll have to start the process all
over again so if you're a business
buiness owner and you want to avoid
dealing with all this nonsense so you
know you can run your actual business
then you might want to check out parod
parod is a staffing agency that
specializes in recruiting this exact
type of cheap overseas talent for you
they take care of all the recruiting
vetting and interviewing so you can
focus on what you do best while saving
you up to 90% on payroll costs all you
got to do is go to pair. o/j with the
link below fill out the contact form and
then you'll get on an intro call with
them on that call they'll learn your
exact hiring needs you'll get assign
your very own hiring manager and then
they will get to work finding you the
best talent possible their strict
selection process weeds out 99.9% of the
job Seekers out there which means you
will never have to waste any time on
anyone with bad communication skills bad
English or that are inefficient they'll
spend the next 2 weeks narrowing down
approximately 500 applicants to the top
two or three and after those two weeks
they'll introduce you to your new
overseas talent and after that they're
all yours these are your employees you
pay them directly you have full control
over them there is no platform task
systems or communication channels needed
par is perfect for you if you're already
running a a successful business you
already have some employees but you want
really good overseas talent that is dirt
cheapap whether you need five employees
or 50 but per is not for you if you're a
solo preneur looking to make your first
hire so if that sounds like you scroll
down and click the link below to go to
P.S slj to get started now as one
founder said we used PA to find us a
support engineer they found us an
overqualified candidate at about 25% of
the cost of hiring in the US the whole
process was super easy and saved us a
ton of time I can't recommend them
enough or take Jason for examp example
the founder of do lashes I've hired from
a number of recruiting agencies who
charged me thousands of dollars and
delivered a fraction of what per did for
me the team was professional responsive
and attentive to my business needs I've
thoroughly enjoyed working with my new
Talent from parod so click the card on
the screen or scroll down and click the
link below to go to P.J to get started
now thanks to PA for sponsoring this
[Music]
video